-You ever see a photo in
the news
and think that headline
should be different?
Well, we'll take care of that
right now.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example, check out
this first photo.
The original headline was...
That headline can definitely
be improved,
because if you only looked
at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Eh!
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
What else is going on?
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
I'd check that out.
And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all we have
for "News and Improved."
We have a great show.